[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
a proof of concept is a demonstration
whose purpose is to verify that some
concept or theory has the potential of
being used this is the Hasselblad true
zoom mod and it is definitely a proof of
concept it's like the textbook
definition of one so moto mods are
already an awesome idea in my opinion
there are smartphones that don't
sacrifice much in the way of design and
then just use some pins and magnets to
connect to a store of accessories that
add functionality for specialty use
cases I mentioned it in my full moto Z
review that even though there's only a
couple of them
moto mods are easily my favorite attempt
at the whole modular smartphone thing
they just work you just smack it on the
back of the phone there's no rebooting
there's no tools no screws no extra
thought required you just take what you
want to attach to the phone smack it on
the back and it just works so why not
another one
why not a camera one so moto or Lenovo I
guess partnered with Hasselblad to
create this the Hasselblad true zoom mod
an attachable camera replacement told
megapixels sensor 10 times optical zoom
something like a 25 millimeter to 250
millimeter equivalent toss in a xenon
flash a dedicated two-stage shutter
button and optical image stabilization
for photos and have them all in one
package that can be snapped onto your
phone seems awesome right just take all
the things that you can't put in a
smartphone because it's too thin and put
them in a mod to take advantage of the
extra space boom done ship it and I
agree it's a great idea but the one
little problem is it's not that good
like the camera itself isn't very good
now don't get me wrong it still does
what it says which is zoom that's what
smartphone cameras are not very good at
doing is zooming in and out but that's
about the only thing that it does better
going through the shots taken on the
tree zoom camera you'll see a lot of
things first off the colors and exposure
are pretty inconsistent but overall it's
kind of underexposed and a little
oversaturated but then also you'll
notice everything is soft the pictures
are lacking in detail from corner to
corner and even the center I ended up
like wiping off the lens on my shirt
because I thought I had like something
on the glass but it just didn't it's
just soft in almost every photo and then
also in almost every photo no
the lighting conditions it just had way
more noise and grain than it should
which is strange even outdoors there was
noise in the shots in fact the more I
shot with this the more I noticed that
the camera that's already on the moto Z
is actually better than the one that's
in the mod the true zoom goes from the
25 millimeter equivalent to a roughly
250 millimeter telephoto equivalent
which is a lot of optical zoom and you
can see it does it also very quickly but
something to notice is the aperture is
fixed while you do it from F 3.5 all the
way wide to F 6.5 so it's not very wide
aperture and that prevents you from
getting a shallow depth of field with
your close-up subjects and it's not
letting a lot of light in which is why
it has to bump up the ISO so much to
make up for it the phone's fixed
aperture is F 2.0 so the true zoom is
actually a worse low-light camera
letting in way less light and that
explains also why there's so much more
noise in every shot all of this plus
there's no battery built into this mod
like there are and pretty much all the
others so it can actually draw a lot of
power from the phone plus it has a very
small not exactly ergonomic grip
especially for a Hasselblad and it has
this wiggly shutter button and is just
generally a plasticy build quality all
around and then to top it all off it
maxes out at 1080p video at 30fps which
is a bummer because pretty much every
smartphone camera coming out nowadays
including the ones that this is supposed
to be replacing can shoot 4k video and
even slow-motion at 1080p so the only
thing that this does better than the
stock camera it's replacing is optical
zoom
obviously digital zoom and smartphones
is really bad it's literally just
zooming in on the picture you already
have but optical zoom can be much more
powerful but how many people are after
that in a smart phone I don't really
know so for 250 bucks which is what this
thing cost right now yeah this is
probably not worth it for most people if
you're a smartphone or mobile photo
enthusiast just use the camera that's
already on the phone it's better and if
you're more of a mobile camera person
you can get a point-and-shoot for the
same money that takes better pictures in
this
I'll leave one link below that looks
like way better but you know what this
all comes down to again now that we have
summarize it all is proof of concept in
1997 Pixar made a 5 minute short film
called Jerry's game that you
new techniques for animating cloth and
human facial expression whoo it was the
first Pixar production to have a human
main character wasn't the best thing
I've ever made you might not have heard
of it but these new animation techniques
graduated up to be used in 1999 in the
full-length Toy Story 2 you've heard of
Toy Story 2 it's really good so look I'm
thoroughly convinced still that motor
mods are the best execution of this
modular concept as far as smartphones go
and I think they're really good they're
really easy and I think I have a future
but right now they're still super
generation 1 it's the first year we're
doing this so they're not that great but
maybe if we give it some time we'll get
our Toy Story 2 but until then don't buy
this thanks for watching I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]